[Applause]
the debates over
that's why did you why did you watch the
debate I watched all three hours of the
debate and I gotta say Jameis Winston
looked really good last night maybe that
wasn't Victor what three hours
come on I mean by the end of it mayor
Pete look like he could buy beer three
hours it was so long that Cory Booker
one point ducked out to catch that JLo
stripper movie and he got back before
anyone noticed that that's a long but to
all eyes of course were on the the big
three center stage Biden Warren and
Bernie are as they are known to their
hips snap crackle and pop
and you see this picture together it
look like one of those weddings where
the ex-husband is invited but of course
again the big issue was health care and
Bernie and Warren of course support
Medicare for all and Pete is for
Medicare for all who wanted and abet oh
I don't know I don't speak Spanish but
Beto went hard on guns did you see that
he said hell yes
take away your ak-47 and when he said
ak-47 joe biden said bingo I always say
ageism is not good you have to take
case-by-case basis with Joe I'm sorry
he's the one who got it look good he
looked pretty good until the end and
then he answered a question about
slavery reparations we're talking about
teachers pay and Venezuela and record
players record it was like watching a
really old dog try to get up on the
couch record players yes because he's
hip he's into vinyl joke's on you
Millennials
look Bernie Sanders has even older
nobody makes any jokes about his a just
on an issue with him because he doesn't
act old you know it's not something
years it's the mileage Bernie owns it
he's like I care about the Constitution
because I wrote the damn Constitution
now thankfully nobody on this stage
really went after Obama this time they
went after Trump yes good good to see
Amy Klobuchar said the country is being
ruled by a game show host and Andrew
yang said exactly we can't have that
which is why I'm offering every family
in America
$1,000
now Trump himself had a relatively quiet
week for him he committed only like
three brazenly impeachable acts so you
know surely but he did fire his third
national security adviser John Bolton he
said Bolton with very big mistakes and
not the kind you can fix with a sharpie
he loves that sharpie that's his thing
now like Michael Jackson's glove he's
got it everywhere after the Alabama
hurricane was such a success he thinks
he can fix anything with that sharpie
yesterday he drew a smile on milania's
face
well it was the anniversary of 9/11 this
week and Trump posted a picture of him
and Melania looking out on the empty New
York skyline and Trump said he was
thinking about the firemen and Melania
she was also thinking about firemen and
yeah and yet they stay together which is
not something you could say anymore for
Sarah Palin and her husband Todd yes did
you see that very sad news Todd Palin
filed for divorce
it just happens they they drifted apart
yeah
Todd filed for the boy they that's what
you know you've had enough when you're
willing to take your chances with the
single scene in Alaska
you